hello my name is Prague I'm a graduate
student at Harvard
today I'll tell you about efficient
algorithms for certifying lower bounds
on the discrepancy of random matrices
so here's a brief outline of the talk
so let a B and M by n Matrix
and Define the discrepancy of a to be
the minimum overall signing X
of the infinity Norm of the vector a
times x
in this talk I'll be focused on the
discrepancy of random matrices a
in particular for the purpose of X
position let's consider the simple model
where the entries of a
our IID standard gaussians
in this setting it's known that the
discrepancy of a
is equal to roughly square root n
divided by exponential and
n divided by m with high probability
this is shown by non-constructive means
so natural computational question
associated with this definition is that
of discrepancy minimization
given an input Matrix hey can we compute
assigning X in polynomial time with a
small value of a times x infinity Norm
so for this problem it's known that the
best polynomial time algorithm can
compute a signing achieving this
competency value which is roughly
exponential and negative log squared M
divided by m
so these two results are summarized on
this axis depicted on the bottom
this axis depicts various
discrepancy values clearly the
discrepancies
Always non-negative by definition
we know that this middle value of
roughly square root n divided by 2 to
the N over m is the true high
probability value
and the best polynomial time algorithm
can compute signing achieving
discrepancy value roughly this second
expression
moreover we don't know of any algorithms
achieving discrepancy values in between
these two
even though we know by these
non-constructive means that such
signings exist with high probability
so I'll tell you three reasons why
average case discrepancy is an important
and interesting topic to study
so first off it's been
studied tremendously for worst case
settings a so it's natural to consider
an average case version of this problem
second the average case problem is
related to covariance coverage balancing
and randomized control trials and the
so-called easing perceptron model from
statistical physics
slightly this is an example of a problem
with a conjectured information
computation Gap
has alluded to in the previous slide
there's some regime of discrepancy
values where we know there exists
signings achieving such value by
non-constructed means but we don't have
polynomial time algorithms to find such
signings
so it turns out that this discrepancy
problem is related to something called
the planted Boolean vector and random
Subspace problem
this is a well-studied problem for which
um there is significant evidence that
such an information competition Gap
really exists
moreover in recent years
um
uh burgeoning Latino research has
developed various tools for reasoning
about
these information computation gaps that
is to say these gaps are inherent and
not due to a lack of creativity on the
part of algorithm designers
unfortunately these tools are generally
ineffective at reasoning about average
case discrepancy bombs
so
in order to
shed further light on this issue in this
work I propose study of the following
certification problem
which is as follows
so the goal is to design an efficient
algorithm which on input Matrix a
outputs a value out of a which satisfies
two properties
so the first property is that for every
input a
the value output by the algorithm is a
faithful lower bound on the discrepancy
of a
the second property we wanted to satisfy
is that for random a for example High ID
gaussian entries
algae way should be close with high
probability to the true high probability
value of discrepancy of a which we know
by non-constructed means
so I'll just give a few remarks about
this problem
so note that the trivial algorithm for
this problem just outputs the value of
zero for every input a this clearly
satisfies the first property but it's
not very interesting because it doesn't
satisfy the second property
so we are interested in designing
algorithms which satisfy this first
property
but output a value that is positive with
high probability
the second remark is that worst case
version of this problem is like a co-np
problem
that is we want to
determine or we want to prove that a
given Matrix
has a large discrepancy that is there
does not exist any signing achieving a
small discrepancy value
note that this is a highly non-trivial
task because
the trivial algorithm for for proving
that no such small discrepancy signing
exists would amount to enumerating the
to the N possible signings and Computing
the discrepancy value achieved by each
of them
so if we have an efficient algorithm for
this problem it's interesting because
the algorithm or the output of the
algorithm is itself a proof that the
discrepancy of a is large
this is in contrast with the discrepancy
minimization problem
where proving that a matrix has a small
discrepancy is simple one just needs to
exhibit
um a signing
the third remark I'll make is that
if we can solve this certification
problem we can immediately distinguish
this distribution of random matrices
from any other Distribution on matrices
which have a strictly smaller
discrepancy way
in contrast with prior work
we don't study the search version of
this problem that is finding an actual
signing
in general the search problem and the
certification problem are not relatable
and the complexities can be quite
different
now I'll give you three reasons why the
average case discrepancy certification
problem is an interesting one
so the first
I'll mention a relevant fact which is
that
it turns out semi-definite programming
based algorithms
fail to certify any non-trivial value
that is with high probability the
inappropriately defined
semi-definite programming value
is just equal to zero
this is notable because for many average
case
problems
we believe that semi-definite
programming based algorithms are optimal
among polynomial climb algorithms so the
fact that
um
this powerful class of algorithms fails
to do anything non-trivial and we don't
know any other algorithm
is itself very interesting in Peculiar
the second reason for starting this
problem is
drawing inspiration from this beautiful
work of 5G came in ofek
who studied uh the problem of refuting
random case had formulas
um as mentioned you know of worst case
version of this problem is uh some type
of co-np problem
it was very natural to study an average
case version to try to understand at
least in a very informal level
relations between complexity classes
like p and p and co-n-p
finally there's a very rich literature
on refuting random constraint
satisfaction problems using
semi-definite programs
the fact that semi-definite programs
fail
for average case discrepancy
certification
gives us an opportunity to
um
potentially
Inspire and design new organic
techniques that can surpass stps for
some class of interesting average case
problems
so these are the three reasons why
average case discrepancy certification
is an interesting problem to study
so I'll now tell you about the two main
theorems of this work
so the first theorem states that there
exists a deterministic polynomial time
algorithm that
on input Matrix M by n which has high ID
gaussian entries as before with M
smaller than m
the algorithm certifies that the
discrepancy is bigger than the value
exponential and negative N squared
divided by m with high probability
thank you
the second main theorem states that if
we relax
deterministic polynomial time to
non-deterministic polynomial time
we get an algorithm which can certify an
improved value that is
exponential and negative n log n divided
by m
so here non-deterministic polynomial
time
algorithm for the certification problem
means that
there exists a polynomial time
verifiable certificate that the
discrepancy of a is larger than this
value
but it doesn't necessarily guarantee the
existence of a Quantum polynomial time
algorithm to find
um such as a certificate or witness that
the discrepancy is large
so I'll summarize these two theorems
um and our
sort of knowledge about the
um average case discrepancy problem in
in the the following figure
again
I'm depicting this this axis which
represents discrepancy values
the trivial lower bound is always zero
we know that this
third expression here
expresses the true high probability
value of the discrepancy
we know from prior work that for
discrepancy values larger than this
fourth expression
there exists polynomial time algorithms
to find signings achieving such
discrepancy value
the main contribution of horror work is
sort of on the lower bound side
so the first main theorem
states that for discrepancy values
smaller than this first expression
there exists polynomial time algorithms
to certify that the discrepancy is at
least that large
moreover if we relax to
non-deterministic polynomial time
we can improve the exponent N squared
over M to n log n over n
finally
prior work and current work leave this
middle regime open
I'll discuss more about this later
I'd also like to
translate these results into some very
non-rigorous and informal complexity
theoretic language to shed a different
perspective on it
so we know that
um
the problem of
um
um the associated decision problem to
this is discrepancy minimization
is in NP we know that the
Associated you know worst case decision
problem of
discrepancy certification is in Ko NP
the polynomial time search algorithms
from prior work
State roughly speaking that with respect
to the complexity of this average case
discrepancy problem
NP is contained in P for discrepancy
values larger than this fourth
expression
our work states that again informally
that for discrepancy values smaller than
this first expression
co-np is contained in p
for this
improved discrepancy value given by the
second expression
coin p is contained in NP and then in
this middle regime we don't know any
non-trivial statements
so now I'll give a few remarks that
put this main
theorems in context
as mentioned these are the first
non-trivial algorithms for average case
discrepancy certification they
outperform semi-definite programs which
is
um not you know no notable example among
many average case problems for which
semi-definite programs are actually
believed to be optimal
second is a corollary of our main
theorem
we give a polynomial time algorithm for
What's called the detection problem in
the negatively spiked wizard model
in some regime of parameters for which
we neither new algorithms nor hardness
results
as alluded to in the previous slide
um
how results raise the possibility that
the landscape of the average case
discrepancy certification problem
actually resembles quite closely
that of refuting random three set
formulas in the unsatisfiable regime as
established by this work of 5A came and
effect
that is to say
there's some regime of discrepancy
values for which
there are polynomial algorithms to
certify the discrepancy is at least
about you
there's an improved regime of
discrepancy values for which
there are polynomial time verifiable
weaknesses that the discrepancy is at
least that value
although we don't have algorithms to
find or compute those Witnesses
and finally there may be a regime of
parameters where they do not even exist
polynomial time verifiable witnesses
that the discrepancy is
um
larger than that value even though we
know by non-constructor means that
no such signing achieving those
discrepancy values actually exist
the final interesting feature about this
work pertains to the techniques which
involve a reduction to the so-called
shortest Factor problem analysis
so there's been a recent line of work
um which demonstrates that these lattice
based techniques are
able to surpass stps for certain average
case search problems
so the present work complements this
recent work by demonstrating the utility
of lattice based techniques for solving
certification problems as well
and I'll give you a brief overview of
the main techniques behind the proof
so our starting point is the following
observation
so consider the polytope S Sub Delta
which is defined to be the set of all
vectors X
so that the discrepancy of x
is smaller than Delta and the
coordinates of X are bounded between -1
and 1.
so observe that this polytope
contains
all low discrepancy signings if any
exist
however it contains also spurious
um
potentially contains spurious Lord
discrepancy signing
this leads us to the conclusion that if
the set as a Delta
contains no non-zero integer point
then we may immediately conclude that
the discrepancy of a is bigger than
Delta
so this gives us an algorithmic uh
approach to certifying that the
discrepancy of a is bigger than Delta
we simply need to certify that the set
as a Delta
which depends on the input Matrix a
does not contain a non-zero integer
point
however in general these kind of
problems are not to be very hard
so we need to relax in some way to allow
this problem that we can hope to solve
efficiently
so to this end one of the tools we use
is an algorithmic version of something
called John's theorem
this guarantees the existence of a
invertible linear transformation t
so that if we apply this t
on the polytope acid Delta
we can sandwich the the transformed set
in between an L2 ball of radius one
and an L2 ball of radius square root n
so given this sandwiching
we can immediately observe that if we
also transform the set of integer points
in our end
we intersect that with the L2 ball of
radius root n
and the intersection contains only the
zero vector
we may immediately conclude that the
discrepancy of a is larger than Delta as
desired
so now let's consider the statement of
this intersection being only the zero
vector
it turns out that uh this
Triumph linear transformation applied on
the set of integer points is an object
called a lattice
so basically this problem boils down to
determining whether a given lattice
which depends on the input Matrix a
contains a non-zero Vector whose Norm is
smaller than root n
so if we can you know determine whether
or not this so-called lattice contains a
short
non-zero
filament
then we can solve the discrepancy
certification problem
and it turns out that this former
problem isn't exactly is exactly an
instance of something called the
shortest Vector problem on lattices as
mentioned this is a hard problem uh to
solve exactly
so one of the key technical challenges
that we surmount in this work is to
demonstrate
how to use an approximation algorithm
for SVP
to solve this discrepancy certification
problem
it turns out that the approximation
factor of the algorithm used for this
shortest Vector problem can be
translated into the discrepancy value
Delta that is certified in the end
so to summarize the main contribution of
this work is that we introduced the
problem of average case discrepancy
certification
we gave the first non-trivial algorithms
which surpassed the performance of
semi-definite programming based
algorithms
and the State of Affairs for this
problem is summarized by this
figure I discussed before
so
as hinted at by this figure
one of the main open directions is to
try to understand whether these gaps are
inherent or
there are
actually algorithms which can close
these gaps
another interesting Direction pertains
to reasoning about the limitations of
lattice based algorithms
so even though we demonstrated that
lattice based algorithms can surpass
stps
unlike stps we don't know how to exactly
reason about limitations of this class
logarithms
finally it will be very interesting to
understand whether there are more
average case problems for which these
lattice based algorithms can surpass
stps
the current work has added one such
problem to the list
it will be very interesting if we can
get a more thorough understanding of the
class a problem for which this
phenomenon occurs
I'd like to acknowledge these
funding sources and thank you for your
attention